Nikhil I just saw you inscribe story
says only how impressive how on earth
did you get a reservation there lucky I
guess that's a wonderful rest don't tell
me don't tell me let me guess
Patagonia Singh Kela hmm if Yusuf soccer
compliment was sufficient Kevin hello
Raj nice glasses
how the hell are ya Paul has mistaken me
for this [ __ ] Raj's on it seems
logical because Raj also works in infra
and in fact does the same exact thing I
do and he also has a pension for
patagonia vests and Gucci glasses Raj
and I even go to the same Copa café in
Palo Alto although I order a slightly
more expensive drink how's the Gemini
project oh it's uh alright oh that's
interesting that's not it's not great oh
well you know hmm how's uh how's Cecilia
she's a she's a great girl
yes I'm very lucky mm-hmm
hey Paul congratulations the Leo project
Thank You Jimmy listen Paul bouldering
sure when how about Friday no can do I
got a 8:30 Reza that's all it's got a
great sea urchin ceviche see Dylan
Friday night how you swing that
I bet he's lying new keys what do you
think whoa look at that very nice picked
it up on Amazon yesterday good switches
their blues and the o-rings or point
twos that's very cool Nikhil but that's
nothing
look at this that is really nice MX
browns good point fours what do you
think
oh jesus this is really super how does
it that would like you get said tasteful
I can't believe that Brian prefers
Zambia's keys to mine but wait you ain't
seen nothing yet
obsidian black and expertly switches
impressive there are nice
let's see John Aldens keys
[Music]
look at that settle off black coloring a
tasteful activation force oh my god the
keys aren't even labeled make you
something wrong you're sweating
okay so you're telling me I just opened
the app I type in how long I piss how
often and what color it is and at the
end of the week it's gonna tell me what
medical conditions I have yeah and if
you get the premium version you'll
actually also find out how long have to
live wow that is really nice so this
one's premium yeah so if you actually
take a look and if the color turns red
that means you have until
[Music]